long does it take to detox the toxins out of my body? I'm looking, I'm talking about the
toxins that showed up the toxic detox test. So regardless of what toxins you have, whether
it's a chemical toxicity from the tech test that's shown on that, or if it's a heavy metal
toxicity or if it's a micotoxin, there's different factors that are involved. The first rule in detoxification
is that if your level of toxic exposure is exceeding your rate or your ability to get rid of that
toxic exposure, well then you're going to become toxic. So yes, so one of the factors in your ability to get rid of
something is your ability to mitigate exposure to something. And it isn't necessarily that one thing. Let's say if I have high levels of
2, 4, D, which is herbicide, and that would show up in the toxic tech test. So let's pretend that was really high levels of that. And I had some
elevation of micotoxins. And I started to do some detoxing, maybe I started to use some sort of key later, some sort of binder. I'm doing some things to support my liver. I'm doing coffee
edamas, I'm doing the casserole packs or just heaty packs over my liver. I'm taking deadly and rude and milk thistle and supporting liver detox pathways, et cetera, et cetera. If you're currently exposed to other
toxins, not even the ones that were elevated, let's say you've, you know, reduced your, let's use the 2, 4, D as an example. That's an herbicide that's a, oh, well we were
herbicide on our lawn. And I was going to this park, which had beautiful grass, most likely used an herbicide on it. And I was laying down in the grass because I just love to do that. Let's say my exposure to 2, 4, D was high.
Thereby giving me elevated 2, 4, D levels of the toxic tech test. Let's say I've stopped that. But now I may be exposed to something else. I don't know. Let's say you're eating more.
You know, panfish because it's summertime, when you like to fish, and it has high levels of mercury. So anything that's going to put a burden on your liver is going to hinder any detoxification. The detox pathways, typically your pond 1 and your
cytochrome p450 pathways, your net pathways, and your glutathione pathways that are responsible for getting rid of toxins that are circulating. Remember, you're exposed to something you, do you breathe it in, you ingest it and you absorb it or you
inject it by going to get it in a vaccine or something like that. It's in your system and it's circulated in your blood. It's going to go through the liver. And your liver is going to get rid of a lot of it.
But your liver can become overwhelmed. And then literally your liver is saying no vacancy. So it circulates around in your blood again. And it's going through your liver again.
If your liver is currently occupied, those liver detox pathways are working over time because of your exposure being so high.
Or because of damaged liver from past, I used to drink a lot or I, you know, whatever, however you damaged your liver, or I have genetically poor detox pathways by rate of detoxification may be slowed.
If my rate of detoxification is slow, whatever is currently circulated by blood may not be able to exit the liver. What's not going to exit any other way, unless you're going to doing the soda, you're out sweating, and you know, whatever. So it's going to be pushed into the tissues, and it can be pushed into the cells.
So that is technically my level of toxicity is what is in my tissues, what is in my cells that we can measure that get us still not a perfect measurement, but we can measure it with a urine test to see where you're at.
And least shows us what your, what's your excreted, and if you're excreted at high levels of keeping your example of 240.
That says that you probably are exposed to a lot of that. So helping your body get rid of that is necessary. So using keylators, using binders, supporting liver pack detox pathways, doing everything that is in that course of the seven phases of detox to make sure I'm getting up. What's on the inside is necessary.
Now, I may have limitations to my liver's ability to get rid of things due to some of the things that I mentioned. Maybe it's genetic issues. Maybe it's previous damage to my liver.
Maybe I am metastasis to my liver. Maybe I have other issues with my liver. So I'm going to have, you know, an inherent, you know, slower rate of detoxification. That's very common in people that have toxicity issues.
So let's say we take an editor, how fast to answer this question. It's very difficult answer, obviously. How fast can I get rid of these toxins? It depends on the accumulation of what you're doing to help your liver get rid of these things.
Plus the accumulation of what you're doing to limit your exposure to all toxins, not just the one that was elevated in some test, all toxins.
And is the answer. So in fact, you read the inherent issues that a person may have with their liver. I've said this multiple times that say two people live in the same household, one shows elevated toxins. Let's pretend if we could have a scenario like this, which is impossible.
That they were both exposed to the exact same number of toxins, same percentage of toxins per body weight.
What it has toxicity issues, one doesn't. It can factor the factors of that would be the limited factors of the liver's ability to detox and the rate of detoxification, which can be genetic.
So a person can genetically have slow detoxification pathways and they just accumulate poisons more easily because they're a slower detoxer.
And we see that a lot with cancer patients, these people just people with cancer, people with toxicity issues have genetically just slower detoxification pathways. They're not able to get rid of things that they otherwise would want to get rid of and that that could accumulate the body because all sorts of problems.
So sorry, but not an easy way to answer the question.
Bottom line, it can take however long it needs to take and ready the test again. That would be a good question. When should I run the test again? I always say six months because it really takes that much time to get rid of stuff.
And don't be surprised if you ran the toxicity test again. And let's say I was elevated in 2, 4, D, 6 months ago. And now that is within normal levels, but something else is now elevated.
Welcome to the world of worldly poisons that we live in. They do our best to try to keep away from these things, but they're sprayed in everywhere. It's sprayed in the skies. It's sprayed on everything.
In all our food sources, even if it's organic, it's still cross contaminated. It's everywhere. These poisons are everywhere. We need to support detoxification all the time. That's why people ask me all the time.
What's a good detox to do? Life is a good detox. You need to be supporting your seven phase of detox all that time.
There's not just such a thing as I'm going to do this detox, and then I'm going to be done. You're constantly supporting vacation. That's the only way to live.
So the more you can do that, the benefit of running a test like this and seeing positive results gives you clues that I have issues with my detoxification pathways. So I need to support it even more.
So lots of times when people run a test, toxicity tests, and they're all clean, that doesn't mean that they necessarily lived a cleaner life than another person, but they just have a really healthy liver. So they're just getting rid of this stuff quite quickly. So that's a good thing, but that's a rare thing to hope that helps.